yo what's up everybody it's
international master Daniel wrench we're
back today on chest coms YouTube channel
to bring you another chess openings how
to play video lecture today we're going
to talk about both the dragon the
mainline dragon and the accelerated
dragon we're going to change the claim
of these videos from two-minute opening
drills to something maybe around 5 or
even under 10 minute opening drills as
being our goal because let's be honest
I'm not that good to cover two openings
in under two minutes as fast as I'd like
to talk and I don't think that would be
very enjoyable for all of you as well so
from now on you're going to see five
minute opening drills I'm surrendering
my my fast-talking flag to make these
videos a little bit more educational and
a little more entertaining and
all-around just a good old time fun
family time so let's do this the the
dragon the main purpose of the Dragon is
to essentially feeing Ketel this bishop
along the long diagonal a1 h8 ok and on
that diagonal you'll find the bishop has
an extremely dangerous purpose not only
does it put pressure on the central dark
squares but because blacks play in the
Sicilian is always involving natural
queenside players we talked about even
in the knight or a bishop being placed
along this diagonal exerting pressure on
all these critical squares can be quite
the dangerous beast over there a
fire-breathing dragon as it's been
called by many players so the main
purpose of the dragon whether it's the
accelerated or the mainline is to put
your dark-squared bishop again the f8
bishop along the long dark square
diagonal there are two ways black in it
can reach the dragon we're going to flip
the board around so that you can focus
on blacks move order here to start with
the accelerated we would play to Knight
to c6 and after d4 takes takes g6
we're heading toward a position where
black would like to put this bishop
along this diagonal again putting
pressure on the dark squares the reason
why black would played this move order
with two Knight to c6 as opposed to
playing the move order with two d6 is so
that at some point he might be able to
move the pawn from d7 to d5 and one move
one example of that would be that in a
mainline accelerated dragon if white
chooses to
of naturally as he does in many open
Sicilians black has the opportunity to
play for d5 in one move as opposed to
playing from d6 to d5 Black has saved
the tempo and has the ability to advance
in the center playing d5 in one move d5
is when it can be played tactically when
it when it works when it's safe to play
is considered an equalizing move and
many Sicilians as it opens the center
and immediately brings more built more
black pieces into the critical area of
the board also it tends to bring more
pieces to help this fire-breathing
dragon exert pressure on these these
pieces in the center so d5 is a move
that black often strives for in many
Sicilians and so one of the main ideas
behind the accelerated that a lot of
people just don't understand they don't
know why someone might play a different
move order is is is that right there is
that black would like to achieve d5 in
one move rather than two if possible so
by playing Knight to c6 and accelerating
the development of this Bishop Black has
the potential at some point to play for
d5 and one move rather than two we're
going to come back to this concept in
just a second because what I'd like to
point out here is that if you if you
wanted to summarize the one disadvantage
behind playing the accelerator dragon
move order it would be that the lack of
pressure black exerts immediately on
this pawn allows white a developing
option that is not possible in a
mainline dragon move order that is the
Mirage C bind after the move C for what
white is done is use this opportunity
use this opportunity where black did not
put pressure on the pawn in the center
to permanently prevent the move d5 in
doing so he's slightly weakened his dark
squares white has white has slightly
weakened the dark squares by advancing
both these pawns to light squares
however the extra space that white has
in this position developing this Knight
out behind the C pawn rather than in
front of it allows white a much better
control over the critical light squares
in the center this theme is critical and
it's something that really defines the
accelerated dragon as that when you play
to Knight to c6 you are taking the
risk of accelerating the development of
this Bishop hoping to exert pressure
faster in the center and potentially
playing d5 in one move rather than two
but in doing so you are allowing white
the option to play C for which is known
as the maroc C bind and a mainline
choice for white in the accelerated
dragon so why does the move order with
to d6 prevent the maroc C blind whereas
to Knight to c6 doesn't well the main
idea is that when you play the move d6
you're you are preparing to bring this
Knight out to f6 more quickly to exert
pressure on white Center and by playing
d6 you provided protection to this e5
square therefore avoiding White's option
of potentially attacking this Knight as
an example if someone confused their
move orders and decided to play an
accelerated move order and then combine
that combine this accelerated move order
with with a mainline move order
basically playing Knight f6 before
they've chosen to play d6 in the center
one of the main issues was that is that
white will capture on c6 and play the
movie 5 and this Knight has nowhere to
go but back home really in as the option
of coming to d5 is a pawn sacrifice that
white would be more than happy to take
as this move order allows white
immediate pressure on the light squares
forcing east 6 leaving black with a
crippled dark-squared outpost color
complex essentially a weak square
complex that he can never undo so the
move order with the accelerated version
with 290 c6 is designed to complete
development on the kingside and only
later on try to get d5 in one move
rather than 2 though in some cases they
will not get it and they will have to
concede to d6 as the maroc c bind being
an example of that where white simply
prevents d5 so black will end up making
the concession and simply settling on d6
whereas when you play the to d6 move
order by creating this this protection
for the knight on f6 avoiding tricks
with e5 you you're able to put immediate
pressure on the center therefore white
simply does not have time to play c4 and
try for a mirach C
as this pawn is just hanging so you see
that if we were to summarize in a very
simple manner the main main difference
in the main difference in terms of
purpose behind the accelerated and the
mainline dragon it would be that the
accelerated dragon has one particular
goal in mind which is to play d5 in one
move rather than two if the opportunity
should arise the main disadvantage of
the accelerated move order would be that
it allows the maroc see buying a space
advantage for white if he chooses to
grab it the mainline move order concedes
this idea of trying to play for d5 in
one move but in doing so allows a more
aggressive development for black on the
kingside putting pressure on the e4 pawn
and therefore not allowing white even
the option to play for the maroc see
bind as this move Knight to c3 is deemed
as the best move to defend the e4 pawn
right away quickly let's talk about the
mainline versions and actually give you
some theory that can happen in each one
of these sicilians and the mainline
accelerated version we have two main
move orders that can take place we've
already alluded to both one being the
maroc C bind and after c4 Bishop g7
Bishop III black attack C for white
defends e4 black and Castle and after a
natural development move for white this
move as possible this move as possible
Queen d2 as possible you will often see
black play d6 and now because of the
lack of space he has in the center
he will concede to make this trade on d4
freeing up this e 6 square for his
bishop as otherwise it would be taken
and continue to put pressure against the
overextended c4 pawn with ideas such as
bringing rooks to the C file and perhaps
developing a minority attack on the
Queen side to give you one summary of a
classical plan in the accelerated Dragon
Roxy mind if white should choose to play
the mainline move order rather than
Amarok c1 black does have the advantage
of potentially getting d5 here in one
move so Y will often choose this Bishop
c4 development followed by retreating
the Bishop to b3 to avoid tactical
tricks and eventually playing the move
f3 as it avoids this shot with nitrous
you for potentially eliminating a key
argh square bishop this position would
be a main line reached via the
accelerated move order after two d6y can
play for either two main wastes two main
ways to approach this position Y can
play for a Yugoslav attack which
involves creating this pawn structure
here as a means to eventually develop a
pawn storm on the Kings side and
potentially either castlelong on move
nine accelerating this attack right away
without wasting developing moves but in
turn potentially allowing the d5 break
we've alluded to or played Bishop to c4
first transposing into a position that
could also been reached through that
accelerator move where we just showed
you and eventually either castling short
and playing a classical type of game or
casting long and developing a Yugoslav
attack the last version that White has
the option to play against the dragon
would be a classical without the
development of the dark square Bishop
first oftentimes in these cases Y will
voluntarily retreat this Knight to b3
unleashing the Queen's open file so is
to prevent the move d5 for all time and
space and slowly try to develop an
attack on the Kings side with the
advance of the F pawn thank you for
watching this summary of both the main
line dragon and the accelerator dragon
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm